Washington journal continues author and
columnist EJ Dionne of the Washington
Post good morning thanks for being with
us good to be here always let's begin
with the news of the day and obviously
the announcement yesterday by George
Tenet a CIA director the headline by
Glenn Kessler on the Washington Post was
he a fall guy or did he truly leave for
personal reasons what's your comment
yeah Washington is so cynical that no
one ever believes somebody leaves for
personal reasons I think he was very
moving actually what he was talking
about leaving for his son and spending
time with his son I think there's the
the popular view at the moment is that
he's about to have a lot of bad news
dumped on him by these various
commissions in these various reports on
the CIA and that it was shrewd to leave
earlier rather than to leave look like
he was leaving under pressure I think
there's a really interesting question
about whether he was pushed out whether
he was used as the fall guy as one of
the newspapers has a headline this
morning this mess as I understand it
this morning White House put put out
word that no they would have liked him
to stay and it is awkward for the
administration at this point it's they
don't really want a big confirmation
fight on a new CIA director right now
with the election so close and so I'm
sure it had something more to it had to
do with things more than just personal
reasons although as I say he was very
persuasive when he talked about his kid
and your colleague mark leibovich has
George Tenon's slam dunk into the
history books that famous line recorded
by Bob Woodward in his latest book plan
of attack right I me that will stick
with him forever lieutenant I think may
it emerges so almost a tragic figure
that's probably overused again in
Washington he's somebody who's really
quite well liked and well-respected when
he when Al Gore called for his
resignation in that fiery speech the
other day he prefaced it by saying also
two nice things about George Tenet
people who know him admire him a lot and
yet he's stuck with two very big
intelligence failures on his watch
obviously one being 911 and the second
being the information or non infamous
information about weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq the book is called
stand
fight back by ej dionne author of also
why americans hate politics and chapter
six why democrats and liberals should
stop being afraid what's your message
with the one of the core arguments of
the book is that for a long time
democrats have spent so much time saying
who they're not that no one knows who
they are I have a line in the book
saying that Democrats are like that
stereotypical old couple that relieves
fights from 25 years ago just to feel
young again i read that lied to my wife
who said that's a great line that's not
us is it and I said of course not we
haven't been married long enough yes
we've only known each other 17 years and
i think that the theme of the book is
that there has been a kind of confidence
and organization on the right side of
politics that has not existed until
recently among liberals progressives
democrats and even moderate Republicans
and independents there's a kind of power
on the right and that democrats and
liberals are often afraid of their own
principles i talk in the book about how
they sometimes speak the other side's
language i quote the distinguished
Democratic activists and Lewis who said
you know we used to talk about
immunizing little children against
disease now we refer to it as
investments in human capital they can't
even speak straightforwardly I think
that's beginning to change and that is
one of the themes of the book chapter 3
the Democratic Party lost its way
because of its obsession with pointless
feuds outdated strategies and old
arguments Democrats complain regularly
that Republicans fight unfairly that
they will say and do anything to win but
Democrats forgot how to fight back they
didn't know what they stood for so they
didn't know what they were fighting for
and I think that's why the Howard Dean
candidacy took off I think that if you
III talk in the book about first how 911
United us and then divided us again and
I think in the days immediately after
911 and actually for some months we
really were unified as a nation then the
president chose to use 911 and national
security in the 2002 election and
Democrats who its kind of support
supported the president pretty strongly
felt that they had been slapped in the
face for their support Howard Dean came
along and said look the this party does
not know if I
use the title know how to stand up and
fight back think he ended up giving the
party a back bone transplant that the
party wanted and I think the reason
Howard Dean didn't get the nomination is
by the time the primaries world around
almost all the Democrats were speaking
in a much tougher way and Democrats
looked around and decided that John
Kerry might be the stronger candidate
but I think there is that mood in the in
the Democratic Party right now former
President Clinton speaking to authors
and book store owners in Chicago book
expo saying that we should be surprised
i'm paraphrasing what george w bush has
done because it's what he promised to do
wit that's half true i think it's a it's
true that if you looked at the what he
said in the two thousand campaign he did
talk about this deep tax cut which he
pushed through he talked about
privatizing Social Security also which
hasn't that but partially privatizing
Social Security which hasn't happened
yet I say it's half true because the the
music the words were very clear and I
think he should have been his he was
less moderate than he was reported as
being but the music was very moderate
and and the the very term compassionate
conservatism put a very different face
on conservatism as a president himself I
used to say he said we need a
compassionate face the policies and
compassionate conservatism don't always
line up with each other so yes the
president did say he was going to do a
lot of these things but he also said he
was going to be united not a divider and
as I say he did give from moderate
signals which and his less turned out to
be less moderate than those signals
suggested which is chapter one in your
book you say how an idea got Bush
elected and then got him into trouble
what are you referring to well I think
compassionate conservatism was critical
i think he understood especially after
the newt gingrich revolution in congress
that the party needed to present itself
in a different way and that the
conservatism needed to be tempered by
compassion if a conservative candidates
were going to pick up moderate voters i
argued that it got him into trouble
because he didn't sort of he didn't
fully live up to the claims of
compassionate conservatism it also
turned out to be much more difficult
than he thought to pass his faith based
initiative and there was a I talk in the
book about a lack of fit between his
budgets and the compassion talk there's
a very funny line from David from one of
his speech writers in a very loyal Bush
supporter who said like conservatism he
sort of talked about it as an
advertising slogan and he said like
conservatism but hate arguing about
abortion try our new compassionate
conservatism great ideological taste
with less controversy Republican tough
Democratic wimps and the politics have
revenged the book by EJ Dionne this is
what the cover looks like stand up fight
back deal Hudson who was on this program
Wednesday the author the publisher of
crisis magazine which is a Catholic
Church publication talked about an
official publication no but if he's a
Catholic and if the origins date back to
the Catholic Church here's what a deal
Hudson had to say about you your
response from the kerry campaign to your
criticism of him only through surrogates
like EJ Dionne and al hunt they are
saying that I my position on Kerry is
being driven by my relationship with the
White House which of course is not true
it's driven by my relationship with my
church EJ Dionne and he said early in
the interview that he has been a
volunteer advisor to the Bush campaign
right well if we can give viewers a
little background on this this is a
controversy over whether John Kerry
should be denied communion it appears
that most of the bishops of the Catholic
Church don't want to do that so far
handful of bishops asst have said
they're politicians who are in favor of
legal abortion should be denied
communion what he's referring to is a
small line I had in a column where I
said that I thought one of the big
problems of this fight in the Catholic
Church that I am a Catholic is that it
threatens to divide we threatened to
divide on party lines about an issue
that really is a spiritual issue and
that Republicans and deal is a voluntary
advisor to the Bush campaign it would
obviously helped President Bush it does
how President Bush to stir this
controversy up about communion Carrie is
the first if he wins gets the nomination
as expected would be the first Catholic
not
since John Kennedy and to cause him
trouble with Catholic voters is
certainly helpful on the other hand you
don't want people out there taking a
stand on this simply because they're
Democrats and it does create this party
fight at what I have written is and what
a lot of Catholics believe is that and
that using communion as a kind of form
of political discipline just isn't a
good idea that's what cardinal mccarrick
of Washington DC has said and I think
that's what most of the bishops believe
that since I've written that I've talked
to more people and also a lot of priests
in the church and I think a lot of
people just don't want the communion
issue to be a central issue of American
policy since the spiritual matter not a
political matter it's fair game to argue
about where a Catholic should stand on
abortion what the connection between
faith and their other views are but it's
worth also mentioning that the Catholic
Church has strong positions on a number
of issues including the death penalty a
very strong stand on social justice very
strong stand on peace EJ Dionne is our
guest our phone lines are open you can
also email us at journal at c span org
what is the EJ stand for it stands for
Eugene Joseph my dad I'm a junior as you
can see there and to their everlasting
credit my parents didn't want to call me
junior or some diminutive of of my dad's
name so they they call me J from the
time I was born I think it's because my
dad was in the Army in World War two
spent a lot of the war in the south and
as you know in the south even though I'm
a New Englander I think the tradition of
using initials from the South got to put
on me and I've always liked it a native
of Fall River Massachusetts now lives in
washington DC graduate of Harvard also a
Rhodes Scholar 44 years ago the campaign
pitch was that you had a Catholic
running for president who would pay too
much attention to the Pope now the the
story is that you have a Catholic who
will pay no attention to the Pope yes
funny that's how I started a column
saying it is it is the great irony of
this that John Kennedy had to prove that
his Catholic views would not have
excessive influence on his presidency if
he were elected now John Kerry is being
attacked because those the church's
positions don't have enough effect on
his politics i'm not sure i'm honestly
don't know how this argument plays out
in the long haul because there are
you know Catholics are a very important
swing vote in the country there are a
lot of other kinds of voters out there
and you know from the polling carried a
little better in the Democratic
primaries among Catholics than he did in
the rest of the electorate so there may
be some small Catholic vote there but
unbalanced I don't think this with this
convenient issue is going to be in any
way decisive in the election and as I
say I think the bishops don't want this
as the form of expression the put as a
form of political expression for Eugene
Joseph Dionne Jr let's get your phone
calls in Memphis Tennessee good morning
morning Steven good morning EJ movie
thank you Steve please don't cut me off
because I have to make a real big point
here so for and what is what a segue
what you were talking about Carrie and
and the Pope and all I'm a great
Catholic and I have three kids and I had
a wonderful Catholic obstetrician who
told me way back in the 60s that the
Pope was living in the dark ages and
there is a wonderful country writer out
there Tom T Hall who wrote a song who I
think Kerry should use for his campaign
called me and Jesus I just want to say
the bridge to you it says me and Jesus
got our own thing going me and Jesus got
it all worked out me and Jesus got our
own thing going and we don't need
anybody to tell us what it's all about I
think that would help him greatly and
also what happened DJ DJ to all the
impeachment hearings that took place
before this ungodly war in Iraq was
begun Ramsey Clark and all the others
made so much sense and and I was totally
hoping for it and it would happen before
the war took place and to me the way
Bush has taken over it's totally
unacceptable and in my opinion he should
be impeached immediately with no
drawn-out wasted time hearings the whole
nation is being ruled by this tyrannical
ruler who needs the reins pulled in
before we have a total catastrophe on
our hands and no matter how he tries to
justify his pre-emptive war he is guilty
as sin did you get it all in color Jessa
well just about just one more point
Steve I'll be very quick I had a whole
paragraph but here on 9 12 Bush wasn't
the Cowardly if he wasn't the Cowardly
Lion
he is he would have immediately set his
sights on hunting down bed Laden because
he knew he didn't have any experience in
military maneuvers and tactics he
figured it would be a piece of cake to
focus on creating instilling fear in
u.s. right up to his reelection and I
wanted Wesley Clark to be in and I think
if Kerry choses him as his running mate
the whole country can be at peace
because we know we'll have double
enforcement there as far as terror goes
it will be all straight as an arrow to
thank you thank you ma'am there's a lot
there let me just if I can pick up on
two quick points are these on the on the
matter of religion and politics I think
it's entirely legitimate for people's
views on political matters to be
influenced by their religious views I
know my own views on social justice and
poverty are very influenced by a
Catholic teaching and Christian teaching
in general and I think that the the the
question is how do candidates present
that to the voters I think candidates in
a pluralistic society have an obligation
to explain things in a way that are
accessible to people whether they share
their religious commitments or not in
terms of impeachment I just I think that
the impeachment of bill clinton was a
bad idea and I think that we getting
away from sort of the regular order of
government is a bad idea one of the
things I talk about in the book is the
conservatives have started pursuing a
number of unconcern of ways of affecting
politics one was a glint impeachment the
recall in California the abrupt
redrawing of congressional district
lines we have elections to throw out
presidents the election is upon us and I
think as the lady suggests the handling
of the Iraq war is going to be a big
issue and what strikes me now is not
only that people who were against the
war from the beginning have been
critical of the press a lot of people
who supported the war have been critical
to the president asking such questions
as why weren't we ready for what
happened to us why didn't we put more
troops in there in the first place now
we're having to hold a lot of troops
they are beyond their as you were
talking about earlier beyond their
original time so I think that will be an
issue in the election but unbalanced
unless unbalanced I prefer I think we're
better off to settle things through
elections rather than impeachment by our
count you have written or edited or
co-edited nine books I think that's
right yes I've written three books and
I've
did a series of books including a number
of books on religion and public life
also recently a book on national service
which is something that I care about a
lot actually I'm very optimistic about
the next generation of Americans if you
look at people who are under 30 they are
one of the most service-oriented
generations in our history and I've
always thought that if they can link up
this service orientation with the kind
of politics they could really become one
of the great reforming generations in
our country's history and with
Washington Post for 16 years covered
politics in Rome and also in Paris
former editorial writer for The New York
Times next call is silver spring
maryland good morning good morning I
can't believe that lady said that the
Pope was living in a Dark Ages when we
have a convicted war criminal admitted
war criminal running for president and
Clinton came out last night he is a
convicted felon he can't even vote an EJ
always defends him and takes up how
brilliant Clinton is the guy is a
convicted felon he can't vote he can't
practice law and the media the left-wing
media's got to get over Clinton is a
convicted felon I mean he shouldn't be
around children for what he did with
Monica Lewinsky using sentiment cigars
or for god sakes what a wicked guy an EJ
defends this guy all the time it makes
me sick and I'll hurt the scum of the
earth just like EJ these people
shouldn't be in the media I mean God
thanks take a little bit Clinton is the
scum of the earth and they just say how
bright a sucker is God wake up come
alive this guy is so awful bye well
thank you sir there's no question about
where he stands and and you know it's
funny one of the things I talk about in
the book is in fact how deeply polarized
our politics is I mean what the
gentleman said reflects a very strong
view in our politics I get sort of three
kinds of email these days I get a lot of
email increasing amount to email you
know first one is from gentleman you
know folks just like the gentleman a
very strong views and basically attack
anything critical of President Bush as
unpatriotic liberal spew to use a word
one of my
used to them on the other side you I get
two kinds one you know thank you for
criticizing the president if the column
is critical and the Third Kind is you
know you didn't hit him hard enough why
aren't you hitting him harder so i think
the corner reflects the polarization
that does go back to the clinton to the
clinton period he did mention by the way
the ladies of the Pope lives in the dark
ages and I do think it's worth
mentioning of the Pope that he has been
on a number of issues an important voice
for what I think most progressives
believe in notably his I got to cover
his visit to that synagogue in Rome has
a voice for human rights and labor
rights and an opponent of anti-semitism
I think it's an important piece of his
papacy that tends to get lost in some of
these other issues and of course
President Bush this morning meeting with
Pope John Paul the second in the Vatican
giving the Pope the Presidential Medal
of Freedom of war the highest civilian
award given by the president first
instituted by Harry Truman and returned
to the White House in the Kennedy
administration coreg nificant of this is
what well I think it's that Pope really
did play a central role in the
overturning of communism in Eastern
Europe and the president specifically
referred to him as a son of Poland and
so that's significant I think the other
thing is what we refer to earlier the
catholic vote a big certain chunk of the
catholic vote is a swing vote and so i
don't think it hurts the president all
to give the Pope this mental even though
the Pope has been critical of the
president's foreign policy and PEG the
Pope is probably closer to the caller
who talked about the Pope in the dark
ages on Iraq than he is to the president
next call is my any good morning good
morning morning hello well first of all
AJ I'd like to commend you on how you
kept your composure at that previous
code and how you commentators but
sometimes take that kind of bashing but
um my question my question refers to
something you were talking about earlier
about how certain Democrats and liberals
have become went for have forgotten how
to fight the good fight could you drop
some names if you'd be so kind as to
which Democrats in which liberals in
which politicians in general right now
exemplify the kind of politician and
political fighter that you want to see
out there
and it could cross the party line and
asking for a specific liberal specific
liberals mean john mccain's i'm vice
president or something like that thank
you very but I don't wanna interrupt you
you are you finished that's pretty much
it that's my I just want to know which
which politicians you think has the best
values and have the best character for
her as how how they could inform the
public debate in the most constructive
ways thank you well thank you very much
for calling first of all I think one of
the things I talk about in the book is
that there really has been a kind of sea
change among Democrats and progressives
over the last year I think that the the
theme stand up fight back two or three
years ago might have been a plea to
people to engage in different behavior I
think now increasingly it reflects how
lots of different kinds of liberals and
progressives are engaging the engaging
politics they really are tired of kind
of eating their words not saying what
they really mean and so I think it's
broadly true in the party I talk in the
book about a number of specific things
that Democratic presidential candidates
did to offer alternatives and you notice
for example Joe Lieberman has thought of
as a conservative or moderate
conservative Democrat and yet he was
very strong and putting forward a kind
of tax reform that would sort of shift
the tax burden away from the middle
class and the poor and toward the
wealthy i think john edwards is
formulation about to america's one for
the privileged one for the rest of us
has a lot in it as a as a theme but I'm
not here to endorse candidates I speak
very admiring Lee in the book and
elsewhere of Senator McCain whom I think
has been very important on on campaign
reform on speaking out for fiscal
discipline I think there are a lot of
moderate Republicans out there who
really do not want politics to move to
the right or very uneasy with the
direction they're taking and I think one
of the interesting questions for Kerry
is going to be whether he makes this
idea of national unity as my friend
David Broder wrote about a central theme
of the campaign because I think one of
the people one of the things people are
tired of E is this polarization that
we've had
over a number of years both during the
Clinton years and during the bush years
from your book for some Democrats quote
there is no way to ever forget the
bitter battles between supporters of
Eugene McCarthy and Robert Kennedy the
dueling anti-war candidates of 1968 for
others the anti-war movements insistence
on ruining Hubert Humphreys chances that
same year and helping to elect Richard M
Nixon is the unpardonable sin George
McGovern won the Democratic nomination
as the anti-war candidate in 1972 that's
more than three decades ago yet some
Democrats insist that the party has
never recovered from McGovern ism next
call is independence kansas good morning
morning morning them mr. Deon you and
mr. carrier what I call and those others
in the church that are true Catholics we
call you cafeteria Catholics because you
only pick and choose what you want in
what's convenient for you and when mr.
Kerry approaches the altar rail in the
Catholic Church after being and taking
communion in another church that is not
Catholic I feel it's an insult to our
Lord and char religion and this is after
of course he calls the news media for
photo ops and just how do you feel about
that if this man cannot even be true to
its own faith what kind of a president
you think he's gonna make Thank you
Thank You caller also this email along
those lines EJ Dionne could you explain
to a Lutheran what being quote Catholic
these days means so two issues they are
related the lady use is a term that is
very popular right now in the church
cafeteria Catholic the idea being that
you don't accept the whole doctrine you
pick and choose the pieces of it you
like I think the difficulty in politics
is that most Catholic politicians I know
of are in one way or another cafeteria
Catholics a lot of the people who are
very strongly pro-life are also strongly
in favor of the death penalty yet the
church teaches and has taught for some
time particularly under this Pope that
the death penalty is at best a very last
resort that shouldn't and and that
usually shouldn't be gone through
similarly on a lot of social justice
issues if you look at what the bishops
have said and what
politicians do there is a disconnect so
I think that that I think the term
cafeteria Catholic is is it is used as a
dismissive term and yet I think it
applies to even many of the Catholics
who would say they are the most faithful
I'm not being critical of them I or the
lady but I do think there is a way in
which that term is used in a one-sided
way against liberals but it's never used
against people who might be on the white
in terms of what the Catholic Church
teaches if there is i'm not going to
hear i'm not here as a theologian to end
or as a priest which i'm not i'm like
that earlier lady i have three kids and
so I don't want to do it that way but a
cardinal bernardin the late Cardinal
Bernardin used to talk about it as a
seamless garment where he saw a link
between the Church's teachings against
abortion pro-life teachings they are and
its teachings on war and its teachings
on social justice and I think there are
a lot of people who are religious who do
try to link if you will social and
family issues with social justice and
economic issues alfred knopf is
publishing one and a half million books
by Bill Clinton how many did sound &
schuster not been close to Bill Clinton
so we'll see what happens i'm lee i just
bought a new saturn so i guess i am the
saturn take his Cadillac Katy Texas for
EJ Dionne of the Washington Post good
morning good morning good morning first
I want to say that I am a Catholic and
I'm very proud to be one and I was going
to say a few things but I'm not going to
because I'll be nasty about it select a
man from Springs Maryland he needs to
get a life and that lady from Kansas
really pissed me off I don't know what
she is but I am sick and tired of people
bashed in the Catholics I mean if you
look they guessed a priest and
everything and another thing President
Bush I voted for him when he was elected
but I won't [ __ ] the trophy him again he
it's an honor to talk to the Pope and he
does not deserve that he is a phony and
I can't stand him that lady from
Tennessee that could he need to be
impeached I agree with most of what she
said thank you thank you I mean whatever
thinks about this program is that I
think more than almost any other kind of
talk show you use sort of surface very
strong views
on both sides talk shows tend to be very
one-sided these days I just want to say
I identify with a lady and saying I
don't like catholic bashing either and i
think you know i am very much shaped by
the church think there are things one
can be critical up particularly in this
recent scandal but i don't think i don't
think most people in this conversation
right now are engaged in catholic
bashing they were having an argument
over what the role of abortion is in in
connection with politics and church
teaching last question you write about
Rush Limbaugh in your book page 59 where
Rush Limbaugh criticized Bill Clinton
and his handling of national security
issues air America with is having its
own financial troubles you want to just
comment generally about Rush Limbaugh
and talk radio in general well I do talk
a lot in the book about how I think
conservatives have had a very successful
campaign over a long period of time to
push the media to the right they've done
in two ways they've criticized any media
that wasn't conservative as liberal
whether it was liberal or not and
created a pressure that way and then
they've created their own new media I
talk very critically of Rush Limbaugh
although I am respectful of the
achievement that he has created
something extraordinary in our politics
I worry about the nature of that
discourse you know to go back to the
caller who talked about Bill Clinton
there's a famous Rush Limbaugh quote
where he said white water is about
health care it was in other words using
issues that were on the side of politics
to you know using personal issues to
affect the direction of policy and a lot
of the criticism of Clinton even though
he gave his enemies plenty of ammunition
to use some of that criticism was
designed to affect you know get in the
way of other things he was doing such as
health care I think that what I don't
know anything about the financial
situation of air America but I think
it's part of the response i'm talking
about in the book that a lot of people
were liberal and progressive have said
wait a minute liberals and progressives
have been asleep at the switch
conservatives have done a brilliant job
of organizing over a period of 20 or 25
years and liberals and progressives are
now coming to the point of saying you
know we better be at least as good
as they have been in organizing a series
of institutions so al franken has taken
the risk of starting something new and
that's a hard thing to do but I think
it's very useful to have an alternative
set of institutions out there because
it's going to broaden the debate and the
bait sure needs to be broadened the
latest book by washington post columnist
ej dionne stand up fight back republican
tufts democratic wimps and the politics
of revenge thank you for being with us
thank you for having me by the way a
couple of calls on president clinton who
spoke in chicago at Book Expo America
Book Expo should say in Chicago the
speech that he delivered yesterday can
be seen on c-span 2 tomorrow evening at
six o'clock eastern and against